Intel's eighth generation of desktop
CPUs is the company's first opportunity
to respond to AMD's rise in CPUs that
truly change the PC hardware market in
March of this year so with the core i7
8700 K Intel bumped up the corn
thread-count for the first time in the
history of the high-end i7 processors
but is it the jump we're hoping for from
Intel our results seem to say so the
8700 K retails for 360 u.s. dollars
which is the highest launch price for a
flagship i7 but not by much the previous
7700 K goes for around $340 the slight
price bump is justified through the
higher core and thread count instead of
the multi-threading quad core design
that's been in place since 2008 on the
first gen ice Evans we now have
multi-threading six core configuration
based on the new coffee-like
architecture in this regard alone we're
getting more performance per dollar
there's another catch from the price
though all eight gen copy link CPUs
require motherboards with a Z 370
chipset all past motherboards including
ones with the Z 270 chipset that
released earlier this year are not
compatible with the new CPUs even though
they all use the same LGA 1151 socket
type that means another 100 to 150 plugs
but if you're on a much older platform
and look in the upgrade that's something
you've already considered as for
technical details the 8700 case supports
a base clock speed of 3.7 gigahertz
across all cores and Kealii boost one
chord to 4.7 gigahertz or two cores to
4.6 gigahertz before we get into
benchmark results let's establish our
methodology we use the ASUS Maximus X
Heroes III 70 motherboard to build our
system and since we want to keep things
as consistent as possible with our past
tests we use the same or similar specs
16 gigabytes of ddr4 ram from HyperX a
samsung 850 pro SSD NZXT x' kraken X 62
water cooler and a reference GTX 980
video card which can still hold its own
in games we're going to be comparing the
i7 8700 K directly to three other CPUs
its predecessor that came out earlier
this year the i7 7700 K AMD similarly
priced Rison 7 1700 X which can range
between 300 to 400
dollars Barack's eight cores and sixteen
threads and AMD's six core twelve thread
equivalent in the risin five 1600 x
that's much cheaper ranging from two
hundred twenty dollars to two hundred
fifty dollars now we have a line up of
cpu focused tests that simulate video
and image rendering and some gaming
benchmarks to get an idea of how
powerful this new CPU is so let's get
into some numbers Cinebench r15 is a
common CPU benchmark to indicate how
well your system handles 3d animation
and image rendering it's well known for
stressing multiple CPU cores and it
shows in the results
the 8700 k smashes on the 7700 k it also
beats out AMD's cheaper 6 cores 1600 X
and it's neck-and-neck with the risin 7
1700 X this is an example of more cores
at work but also the higher efficiency
of coffee like our other CPU centric
tests x264 pas vrai blender and
Geekbench all follow the same trend
shown in Cinebench
but let's move to a few simulations of
more common tasks PC mark 8 is an
extensive multistage simulation of
real-world tasks like web browsing photo
editing and video conferencing it simply
spits out a score at the end and the
8700 K came out on top by a wide margin
the three other CPUs were fairly close
to each other but the 1700 X's distant
second place shows the efficiency of
Intel's coffee wake CPU 3d mark 11
closely resembles video game performance
since it goes through several stages of
rendering 3d graphics first we plucked
out the physics core which is heavily
dependent on CPU calculations and the
8700 K takes the cake by a significant
margin now the overall score is a big
picture result here we see more parody
once we factor in GPU performance the
8700 case still comes out on top but the
7700 K and the 1700 X systems aren't too
far behind a six-minute run-through with
star swarm throws multiple units and
explosions on screen to stress test your
system we ran it twice once with low
settings and once with high settings at
1080p and it appears that it doesn't
utilize anything beyond four cores the
higher clock 7700 K came out on top in
both tests Bioshock Infinite's benchmark
is a bit of an anomaly in that the 7700
K significantly outpaces all the other
CPUs in our 1080p tests with low
settings when we bump up the settings
for maximum
the gap closes but the six and eight
core CPU still fall behind the quad-core
7700 K Deus Ex mankind divided is one of
the more demanding games on your
hardware we ran it at 1080p with a high
graphics preset for a more realistic
scenario and while we see the 8700 K
ahead it's not statistically significant
the game and its benchmark on more GPU
bound and our GTX 980 is the bigger
factor when it comes to performance to
prove the GPU bound nature of games at
1080p with high settings Ghost Recon
wildlands is benchmark gave us similar
results it spits out real-time readings
of GPU and CPU usage and while the GPU
was constantly working at 99% the CPU
workloads range from 25 to 40 percent
but the 8700 K seems to be slightly more
efficient judging from our results with
the i7 8700 K we have a meaningful
change from what we come to expect from
Intel its flagship CPU gets a bump in
core in thread count and we have the
numbers to prove it
especially in CPU heavy tasks however
there isn't much to point to when it
comes to performance in gaming since
games are heavily reliant on the GPU and
aren't here to take advantage of more
than four CPU cores quite yet if you
want a closer look at the core i7 8700 K
check out the written review on GameSpot
comm where we go into more detail about
our tests overclocking temperatures and
all that good stuff
join the discussion in the comments and
as always thanks for watching and we'll
see you soon